hi my name is Salani and i teach science
i've been teaching for five years and
I'm Ryan I've been a substitute teacher
for two years and I'm also in a CT and
SAT tutor today we're gonna talk about
Aging
[Music]
what are some of the things that I've
noticed so far about aging I'm not know
I noticed like I think I actually when I
lift my eyebrow I finally got my first
little baby wrinkles like airlie like if
I really push it I got a couple white
hairs in the front you can't see them
because my hair is curly thank God so
yeah like little things like you know I
might get a little tired if I don't have
coffee but so far it's pretty chill it's
been pretty slow so for me probably the
worst part is you realize that you're
not invincible
I thought you know like I played sports
my whole life did all kinds of like
crazy activities snowboarding whatever
you name it never really got hurt never
broke too many bones and then one day
the freak accident I fractured my ankle
life record all three bones and got a
plate in nine screws in my ankle and now
it acts everyday and now I feel old how
would you suggest like maintaining
youthful look to you being happy from
the inside out and obviously drinking
water what's something about getting
older that you wouldn't have expected I
think when you're young you think that
like just because like when you're an
adult you're not in school anymore so
you have like all this like free time to
do whatever you want you know and it's
not really the case you have to be
working and then you have you know all
those chores that you felt like we're so
annoying to have to do you just there's
a part of your life now and then you get
a change or oil and you got to do your
taxes and you got it's just like it's
like a perpetual downfall of things that
you have to do incomplete and it never
seems to end
wonderful yeah right when you hit a
certain age you just have to be careful
of what you eat cuz you will gain weight
for no reason at all even like I ate a
salad I'm fat okay look like I tried it
so when you're young eat all the chips
and eat it while you can yes eat all
this stuff that you can I am cynical
about a lot of things but life is great
I enjoy Who I am in the life that I lead
but there are a lot of parts of it that
are difficult in frustra
and like monotonous you know what I mean
in like those those small my new she
like the everyday things like just kind
of continue to pile up so like the hard
part about being an adult is like
finding time between doing all that
garbage to like enjoy just life what's
one thing that you would advise your
younger self stay here as a ninja what
is the thing you're most afraid about
with aging growing I guess in to someone
I don't want to be I'm trying to like
live my life and just chase the things
that make me happy but I know that as an
adult I'm gonna have to start worrying
about things that don't make me as happy
like taxes and money I feel like when
I'm older I'll have to really you know
just get a hold of myself I guess and it
everything will come crashing down to
reality after I'm done with college I
get that yeah I mean it's a tough
decision like I got into college within
like initially as an engineer and I was
like this is gonna be what my life is
and then at certain point I was like
kind of like is that what I want to do
with the rest of my life you know what I
mean and I just made the decision like
future salaries be damned I'm gonna do
what I want to do you know what I mean
and I mean part of me sometimes goes
back and thinks like I what if I had to
stuck with that but ultimately I don't
think that I would have been completely
happy you know what I mean like I would
like I would have always wondered like
what if what if I hadn't pursued those
like other dreams so to me it's like you
have to like strike a delicate balance
between like doing what you want to do
and like what makes you happy and like
what you need to do you know I mean and
I think part of being an adult and like
living your definition of what a good
life is is like finding a way to balance
those two about finding balance exactly
you just got to have that little voice
in your head that's like remember you
got one life to live do it the way you
want to do it because you better enjoy
it while you're here how do you like
continue with like motivating yourself
to do that just look at Instagram and
all the crazy surgeries that people have
then you'll get motivated because you
know what people don't work out they
just get surgery yeah
they do they cut it right out just cut
it out I'm on that let me get that
shit's going you know what's really fun
is like just giving away money there's
nothing better than giving away money
and like not seeing any of the you know
benefits to you know through which your
money will go rock the white hair is
like I think that's cool hmm are you
scared about that no I'm not scared I'm
[ __ ] if my whole head turned white I
would totally rock it own it I have like
a little tiny bit in the front and I
don't care it is weird getting older
though it's scary cuz you're like I feel
like a child but I have a daughter what
do I miss most about being a teenager I
guess just like the like sort of like
carefreeness of it you know what I mean
like you kind of get to really do what
you want like sure you have homework and
maybe have chores and like a family
dinner or whatever but like other than
that like you kind of can do what you
want and like the you know you sort of
like get to spend more time with your
friends as you get older people branch
off and all that stuff and it becomes
more of a chore to like like oh look
let's all let's pick a date three months
from now where we can hang out for four
hours you know what I mean with those
people that you grew up with and saw
every single day if I drink a lot now oh
no it's a wrap
like I can't even function what do you
think the best part about growing older
is well the best part about getting
older and this is a tough one
yeah yeah I mean because like my answer
about being young was freedom but
there's like it's a different kind of
freedom video experience when you're
older I guess I can kind of take a
vacation somewhere that I get to choose
or I can you know like if I decide I
don't like a job I can go take a
different job or you know I can say no
to certain things that I couldn't say no
to as a kid and I can eat Taco Bell
every night if I want to you know what I
mean like I shouldn't because when you
get older it doesn't like melt off the
way it does when you're a child but I
have like that sort of freedom which is
nice it's fun to be a kid and be like
childish and I still do it all the time
but like the emotional maturity level
that you attain as you get older it's
just kind of getting like emotionally
smarter is nice it makes you feel good
probably I'm looking forward to most is
freedom earning a lot of money yeah just
having like my own space to do my
thing you know reinvent myself I guess
cuz like right now I'm in like a weird
state where don't really know who I am
and once I figured that all out
hopefully with time I'm absolutely
terrified of growing up it's messed up
scary but it's inevitable so you just
got to face it head-on
I mean it's a but you know that's it's a
part of life so you just got to do it as
you get older it definitely gets better
figures you have more freedom to just be
yourself and you stop caring what people
think you're just like you know what I
don't have time I gotta go to work when
you have responsibilities like the more
responsibilities you have unless you
care you're like I don't get it it's
just like do whatever you know I'm
waiting for the day when I can just like
throw my self-consciousness out the door
eat it eat it I just learned that that
word
[Music]
[Music]